face à vous Pierre Laurent merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous Pierre Laurent
sénateur communiste ben voilà vous avez
accepté aussi le principe du débat et
nous vous en remercions j'imagine que
c'est le débat sur les retraites d'abord
qui va constituer votre principal
interrogation évidemment j'ai envie de
revenir sur le débat des retraites j'ai
écouté monsieur Pradier dans la première
partie de l'émission
Bon vous parlez de ligne rouge moi j'ai
l'impression que vos lignes rouges elles
sont en pleine de trous et qu'en fait
vous êtes déjà sur la position
d'érectionnotique et annoncé ce week-end
le ralliement des LR à la réforme parce
que vous construisez tout un discours
pour dire qu'il y aurait une opposition
entre l'allongement de la durée de
cotisation et le report de l'âge légal
en vérité on se dirige vers une réforme
où ils vont avoir les trois on va voir
l'aéroport de l'âge légal je sais pas si
ça sera 64 euros de choses on va avoir
l'allongement de la durée de cotisation
parce que ça aussi ça sera dans le le
projet gouvernemental et donc on va
avoir avec ces deux choses cumulées pour
des millions de Français la baisse de
leur niveau de pension contrairement à
ce qui est annoncé parce que beaucoup
n'arriveront pas à réunir ces conditions
au moment où ils seront obligés de
partir en retraite donc en fait on va
vers une réforme complète complètement
injuste et bon je vois bien comment vous
vous démonez pour essayer de
faire croire que vous allez installer
des lignes rouges mais en vérité vous
vous installez dans une perspective qui
est une perspective de dégradation
massive du droit à la retraite pour les
Français alors même qu'il y a une colère
dans le pays extrêmement forte parce que
j'imagine que vous rencontrez des
Français comme moi souvent sur le
terrain je ne rencontre pas un seul qui
soit favorable à cette perspective
aujourd'hui peut-être qu'ils existent
ils existent sûrement un peu mais tous
les sondages d'opinion ont l'air de
confirmer ce qu'on entend sur le terrain
c'est à dire une colère très forte
contre ça donc je pense que vous devez
quand même essayer d'assumer avec un peu
plus de franchise ce qu'est votre
position alors que je vous ai entendu
pointillés je savais ce que je dis là je
le dis depuis des mois effectivement
point que ce ne sont pas du tout des
postures ce que je dis sur les petites
retraites je l'ai toujours dit et vous
savez parfois j'ai été en contre-courant
dans ma propre famille politique lorsque
je disais que l'âge légal n'était pas
l'alpha et l'oméga vous savez à l'époque
certaines mes amis me disaient justement
que maline rouge n'était pas assez rouge
vraiment lorsque je dis que nous avons
un problème aujourd'hui nous aurons des
divergences sur certaines aspects nous
avons un problème c'est que cette
réforme elle va faire de ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler à 20 ans des
grands perdants les 43 annuités de
cotisation c'est la réforme Touraine
c'est une réforme socialiste c'est pas
du tout une réforme de la droite en
l'occurrence ceux qui vont commencer à
travailler en même temps qui sont les
travailleurs que vous rencontrez comme
moi qui vont être cassés par le travail
arriver à 60 ans ou à 62 ans je ne veux
pas qu'il soit pénalisé et croyez moi
avec franchise si je dis que c'est une
ligne rouge pour moi c'est que c'est une
ligne et je ne transmise
quelqu'un qui a 20 ans partira donc avec
une carrière complète en supposant 43
années à 63 ans déjà un an de plus que
l'âge légal actuel je prends
et aujourd'hui et aujourd'hui et
aujourd'hui vous avez des gens
effectivement qui commencent très tôt et
il faut traiter effectivement pour les
carrières longues la possibilité même de
partir beaucoup plus tôt vous savez que
nous continuons à défendre le principe
d'un départ la retraite à 60 ans
et pour les autres tout se par exemple
qui vont partir à 20 ans à 21 ans qui
vont commencer à travailler pardon à 20
ans à 21 ans 22 ans avec votre propre
système même on dépasse les 64 ans parce
que si on commence soyons
43 ans tout le monde comprend ça on
finit à 65 je vais essayer de préciser
ce que je vous disais les 43 invités
c'est la perspective de la réforme
Touraine tant que nous ne sommes pas à
l'horizon de la réforme Touraine on est
sur 42 annuités et je ne souhaite pas
que on aille au-delà de la réforme
douane donc c'est d'abord 42 amités et
ensuite 43 mais là où nous pouvons nous
accorder c'est que on a un point de
désaccord sur l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite je ne souhaite pas qu'on le je
souhaite que ce soit la durée de
cotisation qui prime pour ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler après 21 ans ça ne
change rien puisque la durée de
cotisation les fait atterrir à peu près
à l'âge légal aujourd'hui là où nous
avons un sujet et c'est un point
d'accord que je peux avoir avec
certaines de vos amis politiques ce sont
pour les carrières longues on a un
chemin important à franchir encore parce
que nos téléspectateurs le savent
sûrement pour obtenir une carrière
longue il faut avoir travaillé avant 16
ans avant 18 ans avant 20 ans et avoir
cumulé un centre de trimestre souvent on
y arrive pas je souhaite qu'on soit
beaucoup plus souple sur ce sujet et je
le redis et vous pouvez vous avez ma
parole et mon engagement devant vous
mais aussi devant ceux qui nous écoutent
je ne céderai pas sur cette question de
ceux qui ont commencé à travailler parce
que c'est une question on se retrouve
sur cette question précise mais vous ne
pouvez pas dire plus vous allonger la
durée de cotisation plus vous dégradez
la possibilité d'accéder à une retraite
dans de bonnes conditions nous sommes
d'accord quand c'est le contraire moi ce
que vous avez dit tout à l'heure vous
avez dit tout à l'heure les générations
précédentes ont eu des carrières hachées
ça sera trouverez demain c'est
exactement l'inverse les générations
précédentes
des des emplois fixes dans la même
entreprise pendant très longtemps
c'était le cas de mes parents et
d'autres etc de mes des gens autour de
moi lorsque je leur cause aujourd'hui au
contraire ce qui caractérise le monde du
travail c'est les carrières hachées et
bien c'est pour les femmes et bien c'est
utile etc c'est utile plus vous allez
durcir les conditions d'accès à la
retraite plus vous allez dégrader
l'accès mais je voudrais ajouter une
autre chose vous permettez qu'il réponde
quand même
on a un point de désaccord notamment sur
l'âge légal et ça c'est pas très grave
c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle pour
vous et pour moi là où je pense vraiment
qu'on peut avoir un combat je passais
les communs en tous les cas dans
l'hémicycle nous aurons ces combats là
ce sont pour les carrières longues je
souhaite y être attentif autant que vous
l'êtes lorsque je parlais des carrières
hachées tout à l'heure je parlais des
femmes la génération de mes parents de
mes grands-parents avaient moins de
systèmes aujourd'hui que nous avons
aujourd'hui dans les carrières des
femmes et là on a un chemin encore
considérable à réaliser l'écart
de pension de retraite entre des femmes
des hommes étant entre 30 et 40%
c'est-à-dire que c'est encore plus grand
que l'écart de salaire tout au long de
leur carrière c'est absolument
gigantesque sur ça je souhaite que nous
avions sur la question mais moi je ne
rentrerai vous assumer pardon vous
assumez que vous allongez la durée
cotisation quand Pierre-Laurent dit que
elle n'est pas allongée je souhaite que
nous gagnons sur la réforme
sauf que nous n'avons pas besoin d'une
nouvelle réforme pour voir son entrée à
l'application la réforme Touraine portée
par les socialistes
par la gauche enfin pardon pas par les
communes
cette réforme Touraine je souhaite qu'on
la conserve telle qu'elle est qu'on
aille pas au-delà parce que c'est
inutile et là où nous avons un sujet
considérable ce sont les 8 milliards
d'euros de pension d'invalidités que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure je sais que
votre famille politique le revendique et
vous avez raison on sait aussi qu'on va
avoir un effet de bord le rapport de
s'adresse nous dit que si on augmente
seulement l'âge légal sans aucune autre
mesure on va passer de 8 milliards à 12
parfois un peu plus peut-être 13
milliards d'euros de pension
d'invalidité et ce n'est pas le rapport
au travail que vous souhaitez ça fait la
journée avec l'autre remarque que je
voulais vous faire c'est qu'en fait
c'est très fort son grand tort c'est
qu'elle passe à côté du grand sujet des
Français parce que le grand sujet des
Français aujourd'hui c'est l'emploi
c'est les salaires c'est la qualité de
la production et des services et des
services publics en particulier si nous
nous attaquons à ces questions là
c'est-à-dire si nous créons tous les
emplois qui manquent dans le pays et on
sait qu'aujourd'hui il en manque partout
et beaucoup donc dans les services
publics mais aussi dans la production
industrielle tout on parle de ça tous
les jours si on s'attaque à ça nous
n'avons plus de problèmes de financement
des retraites donc en vérité la réforme
qui joue actuellement pour dégrader et
les conditions de retraite c'est une
réforme qui va faire payer
haut retraité au futur retraités
une absence de politique sérieuse en
matière d'emploi en matière de salaire
en matière de de qualité d'embauche pour
la production et les services
vous comprenez on va dégrader les
conditions d'accès aux retraites aux
infirmières alors que la question c'est
que si on embauchait et si on formait si
on embauchette toutes les infirmières la
solution il faut les former il faut mais
oui mais la formation des infirmières en
quelques années ça peut avancer très
vite je peux avancer très vite et très
fortement et si on fait ça et même si ça
prend 10 ans vu que les niveaux de
déficit sont en vérité très faible
aujourd'hui au niveau des retraites on
trouvera les conditions d'un équilibre
complet du régime etc et si on le fait
dans tous les domaines si on ne fait pas
ça on va cumuler un manque de recettes
qui va continuer à s'aggraver avec une
dégradation des conditions d'accès à la
retraite et bien je partage votre vision
alors à ce moment-là il faut pas faire
cette réforme il faut voter contre je
vais aller rassurez-vous on aura aussi
des points de désaccord mais si on
s'arrête un instant historiquement on a
eu la droite et les communistes beaucoup
beaucoup de divergence et on en a encore
et tant mieux pour vous comme pour moi
mais sur la valeur du travail je pense
qu'il nous est arrivé d'avoir le même
respect de l'effort et le respect des
travailleurs et vous avez très tout à
fait raison de dire que aujourd'hui le
déséquilibre de notre système n'est pas
seulement lié à une question
démographique il est lié au 35 heures au
fait qu'on travaille moins qu'il y a
moins d'emplois qu'on a des
industrialisé ce pays qu'on a entre 4 et
500 000 emplois vacants dans les
secteurs en tension etc etc on sera pas
d'accord sur les solutions solutions que
je proposais de travailler essentiel 38
oui le constat c'est important de
constater créer à ça lorsque je n'ai pas
on règlerait le problème des retrait je
le reconnais totalement
les conditions d'accès et même on
pourrait progressivement
compris à mes amis politiques nous ne
pouvons pas
appréhender la réforme des retraites
seulement par le petit bout de la
lorgnette il faut aussi revoir du monde
du travail et quand je propose la
semaine de 38 heures en quatre jours on
aura des désaccords sur l'idée mais je
sais ce que vous allez en dire mais de
mon point de vue de droite ça me permet
elle permet aussi de redire qu'il nous
faut mais quand produire davantage moi
je suis d'accord sur une idée c'est que
la France globalement peut mieux
travailler et plus travailler et plus
travailler si on fait travailler ceux
qui ne travaillent pas qui sont au
chômage à qui on impose des carrières
hachées à qui on ne donne pas de travail
après 50 ans parce qu'on les vire des
entreprises mais pas faire
continuellement travailler plus ceux qui
sont au travail et c'est à nouveau ce
que vous proposez alors vous vous le
proposez d'une manière différente mais
vos recettes c'est toujours les mêmes
c'est continuer à faire travailler plus
ceux qui travaillent en laissant sur le
carreau tous ceux que je vous assure
accéder au travail je vous assure que si
les recettes que si vous permettez les
recettes que je propose sont un peu un
peu nouvelles mais tu me convient je
conviens que ça puisse être perturbant
mais y compris vous savez pour mes aux
amis politiques sauf que j'appartiens à
une génération qui est une génération
qui a soupé des 35 heures et d'ailleurs
qu'on a compris que les 35 heures donner
un confort de vie mais ne permettait pas
de profiter de ses loisirs parce que on
ne pouvait pas gagner davantage et donc
j'ai beaucoup de ma génération qui
cherchent à pouvoir travailler davantage
portrait le jugement que vous voulez
là-dessus pour avoir un salaire meilleur
pour mieux faire vivre leur famille et
de pouvoir organiser leur temps de
travail différemment c'est pas possible
pour toutes les entreprises j'en ai
conscience mais je pense que c'est un
sujet que nous devons explorer comme
d'ailleurs la Belgique est en train de
le faire de manière assez intéressante
c'est ce que la droite a travaillé plus
pour gagner plus c'est ce que la droite
de Nicolas Sarkozy essayer de faire
croire aux Français
elle ne correspond pas à ce qu'attendent
les Français parce que dans énormément
de filières les gens s'épuisent au
travail et aujourd'hui ce qu'il demande
c'est pouvoir au contraire pouvoir
respirer en plus depuis la pandémie il y
a beaucoup de gens qui s'intéressent sur
le sens qui s'interroge sur le sens de
leur travail donc les gens veulent
pouvoir travailler mieux peuvent voir
respirer dans leur vie et gagner
correctement leur vie et si on
s'occupait de d'aller dans cette
direction et bien on donnerait du
travail à plus de monde et on arriverait
à produire mieux la forme de meilleures
services à la société donc on
travaillerait ou bien collectifs je
crois que la faute originelle de la
gauche mais d'ailleurs votre président
de parti
la dit assez justement je trouve la
faute originelle de la gauche et d'avoir
dégradé la valeur du travail vous savez
comme moi parce que vous rencontrez des
travailleurs tous les jours je le sais
que le travail
et c'est pour ça votre temps oui c'est
vrai c'est vrai que Monsieur Roussel l'a
dit et je suis d'accord avec lui sur ce
point-là il nous faut retrouver la
valeur du travail parce que c'est ce qui
à l'époque de l'après-guerrement de la
reconstruction a permis d'irriguer
l'ensemble de nos systèmes de solidarité
on aura des désaccords sur les solutions
mais on peut avoir un point d'accord
pour dire que c'est par le travail la
revalorisation du travail et de l'effort
qu'on peut assumer toutes les formes de
solidaire pendant qu'on travaille des
bonnes conditions de travail un droit à
la retraite méritée suffisamment tôt
pour pouvoir profiter d'une retraite en
bonne santé parce que on parle du temps
dont on dispose après la retraite mais
le problème c'est d'avoir un temps de
repos en bonne santé
du bien à la société parce qu'on sait
que les retraités sont extrêmement
actifs dans la société par exemple dans
la vie associative nous sommes d'accord
je reviens sur 38 heures sur 4 jours
quel est l'intérêt l'intérêt est associé
deux valeurs qui pour moi sont
importantes la valeur de l'effort et du
travail aujourd'hui on travaille autour
de 36 heures en moyenne dans notre pays
un peu plus passer à 38 heures c'est
gagné deux heures de plus donc de
salaire mais aussi de cotisations et
donc de système qui irrigueront de
cotisations qui irrégorithme c'est le
travailler plus et les quatre jours
parce que la société a changé
et que je le vois bien aujourd'hui
compris dans des grandes entreprises
industrielles j'en ai une dans le Lot
qui dans l'industrie agroalimentaire ils
sont en train de travailler sur cette
aménagement des semaines et je ne veux
pas qu'il n'y ait que les cadres qui
puissent bénéficier de cela ce qui est
déjà le cas souvent aujourd'hui avec des
semaines de 4 jours le rapport au
travail plus pour une qualité de vie
supérieure c'est travailler plus gagner
plus et travailler mieux alors je sais
que parfois ça peut perturber y compris
à droite mais au fond je crois que ça
correspond aux aspirations notre société
sans sacrifier une valeur fondamentale
que les 35 heures avaient sacrifié c'est
la valeur du travail et de
l'efforts
des 35 heures de des créations d'emplois
qui devaient aller avec c'est pareil ça
c'est une théorie à l'hôpital on n'a pas
voulu on a fait les 35 heures mais on
n'a pas voulu créer les emplois
parce que c'est une chimie aujourd'hui
le parler dans l'impasse à cause de ces
politiques chimères le partage du temps
de travail
ne produit pas plus d'emploi et surtout
ça a un stylé dans la société l'idée que
le travail était un problème je ne le
crois pas d'où vient cette idée qui vous
parle de ça ici personne ne vous dit que
le travail est très bien mais lorsqu'on
défend les Français au travail le
travail est on peut le rendre
intéressant on peut le rendre
épanouissant on n'est pas obligé
d'épuiser les gens au travail on n'est
pas obligé de toujours intensifier le
travail c'est même ça d'ailleurs toutes
les études le montrent qui dégradent
souvent la qualité du travail parce que
les gens quand ils commencent à être
épuisés fatigués stressés qui ne peuvent
plus se concentrer sur le travail
produisent un mauvais travail allez
interroger des gens dans les entreprises
ou dans l'espace qu'il vous diront tous
au moins travailler correctement
comme pour répondre à Elisabeth
Martichoux à l'instant cette idée-là
elle sort pas de ma tête un jour de rêve
ou d'aller collerie forcée non cette
idée là elle vient des discussions que
j'ai avec les entreprises avec les
Français depuis des années
déjà y compris industriel et me disent
tester cette idée tout le monde ne
pourra pas le faire mais commençons
je respecte beaucoup les chefs
malheureusement sur sur l'énergie
j'avais une question mais là on sera
peut-être un peu plus convergent parce
que je vous ai entendu tout à l'heure
on est dans une situation catastrophique
à mon avis on n'a rien vu parce que les
prix de l'énergie sont en train d'être
anglais les foyers mais les TPE les PME
les collectivités locales
donc il faut s'attaquer sérieusement le
problème moi je crois que le cœur du
problème vous l'avez évoqué tout à
l'heure c'est qu'il faut retrouver il
faut se déconnecter du marché européen
de l'électricité actuel pourquoi parce
que nous avons des prix qui n'ont rien à
voir avec les prix de production dans
notre propre pays alors que nous sommes
des producteurs d'électricité qui sont
capables de satisfaire leurs besoins
même si on a besoin aussi
d'interconnexion mais là dessus je pense
qu'on est d'accord
nous nous allons soumettre avec mon ami
Fabien gay une proposition de résolution
européenne sur ce thème jeudi prochain
au Sénat je crois pas que vos amis des
LR soit décidée à la voter à cette
heure-là mais on va essayer de les
convaincre donc si vous avez un peu
d'amis dans le groupe des réponses vous
pouvez peut-être leur conseiller de
voter parce que c'est exactement la
proposition que nous faisons parce que
quand j'entends Bruno Le Maire se
satisfaire du fait qu'à 280 euros
du méga on devrait être satisfait on se
moque du monde je veux dire on est à 5
ou 6 fois le prix de production de
l'électricité en France oui il y a
convergence mais sûrement parce que
historiquement on a fait partie de ceux
qui avaient fondé aussi la souveraineté
les gaullistes et les communistes fondé
la souveraineté énergétique de notre
pays il y a convergence sur la sortie du
marché européenne l'électricité il y a
convergence sûrement sur le fait de dire
que on ne peut pas continuellement
soumettre la spéculation boursière la
question de l'électricité et puis il y a
une autre convergence parce que c'est un
combat que nous avions mené en commun
ici l'Assemblée nationale je m'en
souviens sur le refus de mettre en
concurrence nos barrages
hydroélectriques qui sont le patrimoine
des Français et qui relèvent notre
souveraineté
je pense que la France devrait cesser de
se laisser embarquer dans des
négociations qui n'en finissent pas il
faut dire à la Commission européenne que
pour la France cette question est
tranchée nous ne toucherons pas à la
maîtrise publique des barrages
hydroélectriques point final il faut
être un peu ferme sur cette question
c'est de travailler au corps les
sénateurs et l'Air Force voter
l'approprier ça peut être réglé ce
problème
nationale jeudi après-midi
cette proposition de résolution